did you see this investigation the New
York Times did on nail salons I don't
know about you but I like getting
manicures but not if it means supporting
toxic work environments or exploitation
so how are we supposed to know which
salons are legit well I really need a
manicure so I did some digging turns out
the nail salon industry has tripled in
the last 20 years in fact it's the
fastest growing sector within the beauty
industry you know there's a starbucks on
every corner well for every Starbucks
you see there are four nail salons but
the industry's got a lot of problems the
chemical that manicurists are exposed to
four hours every day are linked to a
whole bunch of health problems like skin
rashes asthma headaches even birth
defects or miscarriages so I decided to
go to a place that's on the certified
healthy nail salon list published by the
SF Department of the Environment so I
know it's not using super toxic
chemicals and as a healthier work
environment the problem is this
certification is voluntary and only
about 24 of the 250 so nail salons in
the city have gone through with it and
not all cities have such a certification
program so what should you look for when
choosing a healthy nail salon
first gloves nail salon staff should
wear gloves especially when handling
harsh chemicals ask your salon if they
use 33 products that is products without
the toxic trio that causes all those
health problems look around and see if
your salon has ventilation especially
where gel and acrylic nails are being
done you also want to make sure your
salon doesn't use nail polish remover
with acetone or nail polish thinner with
toluene and methyl ethyl ketone of
course this question is problematic
because the FDA doesn't actually require
an ingredients list on professional
cosmetics okay so I know how to find out
if a nail salon is a healthy enough
environment to work in but what about
labor violations almost half of
manicurists are Asian immigrants and
they're often exploited with low wages
and long hours I met up with Gina sedo
an attorney who represents nail salon
workers so going into a nail salon
someone like me how can i tell whether
there are labor violations going on
there not what are some good signs and
what are some bad sign there are some
guidelines some general guidelines
postings employers in California are
required to post with the minimum wages
there's also other postings for workers
compensation
mule and rest breaks if you're familiar
with the kind of the price of the
average manicure and you go to an
establishment where it seems extremely
cheap or a lot lower than what you're
expecting it's good for consumer to
think you know where those costs being
borne out notice whether or not there's
windows miss long I notice whether or
not there is a break room and you are
able to see it are the windows in that
break from our folks our employees
taking breaks you notice I'm taking
breaks and where are they taking them
one way to skin it to ensure that the
employees actually receiving the full
tip is to pay them in cashion together
sent directly if they see any health and
safety violations they can also go to
cal sure they can file an anonymous
complaint so I'm glad I now know what it
takes to get a socially responsible
manicure but if you don't feel like
dishing out a few extra dollars remember
you can always do it yourself
you